slap bang in the middle of the Atlantic
Ocean the biggest chef of its era the
men on board have no ordinary mission
they're trying to change the shape of
the world in the 1850s the Victorians
are wrestling with a problem their world
is just too big
they have managed to shrink some of it
with networks of Telegraph cables that
carry messages instantly across cities
countries even continents but not across
most of the world's surface because when
information has the oceans at screeches
to a halt good news and bad profit and
loss declarations of love and war all
have to travel by ship send a quick note
to America you'll be waiting four weeks
for the reply so why not fire up the
ocean well they try and fail
spectacularly the cables too thin the
ships are too small the jobs just too
big and this isn't the only project to
go spectacularly wrong engineering
megastar Isambard Kingdom Brunel has had
another one of his big ideas to build a
Victorian supertanker sexes times bigger
than any other ship afloat she's called
the greatly stunts and she's cursed from
the off the construction company goes
bust the launch fails and then Brunel
dies leaving his friend Daniel Gooch
holding the baby he vows to turn her
fortunes around with this engineers have
designed a new Telegraph cable to work
undersea they make 2,300 miles of it
enough to reach America by so heavy that
no ship on earth can carrier except the
great eastern they attach one end of the
cable to Britain and together with a
hundred and twenty sheep 20 pigs and
twelve oxen to feed the 500 men on board
and they set off on their mission to
strength the Atlantic
day in and day out night after night
through storm and fog they pay the cable
into the ocean while in Mission Control
they watch anxiously to see if the
cables still getting a signal from the
motherland and they almost make it but
just a few days off the American coast
the signal flatlines disaster the cable
snapped it's over
but Gooch is not the quitting kind he
and his business partners stick their
own fortunes on one vinyl gamble a year
later the Great Eastern heads west again
and on Friday July the 27th 1866 a dream
is still alive when the coast of America
is sighted and the connection is finally
made two continents touch clasp hands no
longer so far apart Gooch and the Great
Eastern didn't stop there they took on
the world putting new lines on the map
new ways for nation to speak unto nation
making the earth a smaller place and the
Information Age a reality
[Music]
you